-In the wake of Georgia's
draconian Voter Suppression Law
and as coronavirus cases
continue to climb back up,
Republicans are trying
to cancel everyone
from Major League Baseball
to Dr. Anthony Fauci.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The modern GOP is intellectually
bankrupt and bereft of ideas.
They don't have
popular policies,
and that's why they
lost the presidency
and both Houses of Congress
and spend all their time whining
about the dumbest [bleep]
on Earth,
like Dr. Seuss
or Mr. Potato Head.
Although, they're probably
just mad at Mr. Potato Head
because his face is more
life-like than theirs.
Are you seriously telling me
Rudy wouldn't look more normal
with Mr. Potato Head's
facial features?
Now, that's a lawyer
fit for a President.
"Why you smiling, Rudy?
We got indicted."
"Oh, sorry, Boss.
Wrong mouth."
[ Laughing ] It's a movement --
It's a movement built entirely
on racism,
paranoia,
and fake cultural outrage.
Just take these actual chyrons
from real Fox News segments
over the last few weeks --
"comic book series
snubs Melania Trump"
and "cancel culture
targeting trees."
How did a comic book series
snub Melania Trump?
Did the X-Men not cast her
as the new Emma Frost?
Because she would make
an insanely good Emma Frost.
[Bleep]
She did get snubbed.
Also, I can't believe
they actually found a way
to get outraged about trees.
You can't win with these people.
They used to accuse the left
of hugging trees.
Now they accuse the left
of canceling trees.
You know who actually
tried to cancel trees?
The Once-Ler, a character
created by Dr. Seuss,
who Fox News claims
has also been canceled.
But wait a second.
Books are made from trees.
So by Fox logic,
does that mean Dr. Seuss
tried to cancel trees
by writing books
about saving trees?
If you pose that question
to Brian Kilmeade,
he will short-circuit like
an android in a sci-fi movie.
Though, honestly,
you'd get the same result
from a Denny's place-mat maze.
"He's supposed to get
all the way over there
from all the way over here?"
Republicans have taken their
supposed cancel culture
obsession so far,
they're actually proposing
real legislation about it.
They want to use
the power of the state
to cancel speech or activism
they don't like.
For example, yesterday,
Senators Ted Cruz, Josh Hawley,
and Mike Lee
introduced legislation to punish
Major League Baseball
by stripping it
of its antitrust exemption
after the MLB moved
its All-Star Game in protest
of Georgia's egregious
new Voter Suppression Law.
And again, let's just remember
that the Georgia law
is so extreme
that it actually
makes it a crime
to offer food or water
to voters waiting in lines.
Even Lindsey Graham,
who supports the law
and has spread the big lie
about nonexistent voter fraud
that motivated the Georgia bill,
could not defend that.
-Senator, why on Earth,
if Americans are willing
to wait hours to vote,
would you make it a crime
for people to come
and give them a bottle of water?
-Well, we --
All I can say is that
that doesn't make
a whole lot of sense to me.
-Even Lindsey Graham
was speechless,
a man who has,
on multiple occasions,
given lengthy speeches
on the Senate floor
like an actor doing
a David Mamet monologue
in an audition for
the local community theater.
"As you all know, first prize
is a Cadillac Eldorado.
Anyone want to see
the second prize?
Second prize
is a set of steak knives.
Third prize is you have to
live with my meemaw
and wash her feet
so I can finally leave
this one-horse town
and make something of myself.
I'll teach them how to wash them
how you like, Meemaw!
Geez and also Louise!"
That's how indefensible
the Georgia law is.
And yet Republicans want to use
the power of the state
to silence anyone
who opposes it,
and they're doing it
under the guise
of supposedly opposing
monopolies and corporate power.
-Three Republican senators
are looking to put pressure
on Major League Baseball
after it decided to pull the
All-Star Game out of Georgia,
the League making the move
to protest
Georgia's controversial
new voting law.
Senators Ted Cruz, Mike Lee,
and Josh Hawley
are introducing legislation
today
to eliminate a nearly
century-old antitrust exemption
from Major League Baseball
as a way
of punishing the League.
-On the Republican side,
you're really seeing eyes opened
to the power and danger
of these monopolies.
I think voters already know it.
I mean, they're living it.
They're being censored
on social media.
They're living in fear
that these banks are
going to cancel them,
that these big corporations
are going to cancel them.
-I'm sorry, you think voters
are living in fear
that Coca-Cola
or United Airlines
are going to cancel them?
And what do you mean they're
afraid banks are going to
cancel them, too?
I mean, the closest I've ever
come to having a bank cancel me
was when I got dragged away
from a Coinstar machine
because it got jammed up
on some Pogs and Canadian coins.
"I'm sorry not everything
in my big-ass jar
isn't a U.S. coin with
some dead white guy on it.
I'm sorry you don't have room in
your coin-counting metal mouth
for my Domino's Pizza Noid Pog."
Also, yeah, sure,
Republicans are totally
having their eyes opened
to dangerous corporations
after they shoveled $2 trillion
in tax cuts
into the pockets of corporations
like Amazon,
which, by the way, paid zero
in federal income taxes in 2018,
thanks in part
to the GOP tax cut,
not to mention all the other
regulatory rollbacks
and tax breaks
and other giveaways
Republicans have thrown at large
corporations over the years.
Republicans punish corporations
the way clueless dads
punish their kids.
"Oh, you're smoking
Dad's cigarette?
Well, maybe you'd also
like a glass of scotch
and a nice steak, too.
You would?
And how do you like it cooked?
Hold on, I'm gonna write this
down so I don't get it wrong.
Pink in the middle.
Okay, I'll have that for you
in one minute.
Can I get you some bread while
you wait and learn your lesson?"
The way you know
this is all bull[bleep]
is that progressives like Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
have actually taken on
big corporations
by, among other things,
using the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau
to fight predatory
corporate practices
or by proposing
real detailed plans
to break up big tech companies.
They've already been doing
that stuff for years,
and they were met with either
silence or hostility
by fake populists in the GOP.
In fact, Bernie even
went down to Alabama
to support the Amazon union
drive there.
Where was supposed
anti-corporate crusader
Josh Hawley?
Probably peeling off
his morning face mask
while listening to
Huey Lewis and the News.
And, by the way, these same
Republicans who pretend
to be pro-worker
also pretended to be anti-war
during the Trump years
when they suddenly started
decrying endless wars,
even as Trump was showing off
giant posters
of all the weapons
he was selling to Saudi Arabia
in the Oval Office
like an eighth grader
who threw together
a history class project
at the last minute.
"So as you can see,
during World War II,
they used boats,
but they also used planes.
And interestingly,
they also used spaceships,
little space men."
So given that Republicans
pretended to suddenly care
about ending endless wars
during the Trump years,
you'd think they would have
been thrilled
when President Biden
announced that the U.S.
would finally withdraw troops
from Afghanistan by September,
20 years after the war began.
And it is insane that this
has not happened yet.
The war in Afghanistan should
have ended a long time ago.
Last time we were in a war this
long, it starred Alan Alda.
That's a joke for
the TikTok crowd.
Anyway, this will not shock you.
The same Republicans
who cheered on Trump
are now opposed
to ending endless wars.
-Precipitously withdrawing
U.S. forces from Afghanistan
is a grave mistake.
It is a retreat
in the face of an enemy
that has not yet
been vanquished,
an abdication
of American leadership.
-Oklahoma Senator James Inhofe,
the top Republican on the Senate
Armed Services Committee,
called the President's decision
premature.
-It's ludicrous.
-It's an action South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham
disapproves of.
In a statement,
the Republican said, quote,
"If reports are accurate
that President Biden
is withdrawing all forces
from Afghanistan,
it's a disaster in the making.
A full withdrawal
from Afghanistan
is so irresponsible."
Graham referred to the action
as, quote, "dumber than dirt."
-Seriously,
what do these guys want?
A permanent military presence
in Afghanistan?
It's been 20 years.
Nothing that goes on
for that long stays good,
with the exception of
"Law & Order: SVU,"
which, if Biden keeps his word,
will run longer
than the U.S. war
in Afghanistan.
Congratulations to you all,
but bad news -- you've been
reassigned.
So sometimes Republicans pretend
to be anti-corporations,
then they oppose raising taxes
on corporations.
Sometimes they pretend
to be anti-war,
then they oppose ending wars.
What all of this shows is
that the Republican party
has no actual
ideological principles,
no core beliefs
other than racism, paranoia,
and feigned cultural outrage
against anything they perceive
as even a mild infringement
on their right to do
whatever the hell they want.
For example, even as
COVID cases climb back up
and public health officials
worry
about one last surge
before summer,
they're still spreading
dangerous misinformation
about lockdown,
social distancing, and masks.
And, yes, vaccine distribution
has been a huge success so far.
Just a few days ago,
we hit a new record
at 4.6 million vaccinations
in one day,
and officials have pledged
that the Johnson & Johnson pause
won't slow things down.
In fact, Pfizer just announced
they'll be able to produce
10% more of it's highly safe
and effective vaccine
by the end of May.
And, yes, real-world studies
of vaccinated groups,
from the Mayo Clinic to the CDC,
to front-line healthcare workers
to nursing-home staff,
have shown the vaccines
to be incredibly effective.
But while cases are still high,
we should all continue
to remain cautious.
It's just
the decent thing to do.
I mean, I still wear my mask
and keep my distance
until cases are down,
and everyone around me
is vaccinated,
even though I already
got my second shot,
which I was thrilled about,
even though it felt like
Hugh Jackman
had punched me in the deltoid,
which actually happened.
That was so long ago,
we were still in Afghanistan.
One of the GOP's most aggressive
purveyors of COVID lies
and staunchest
anti-mask crusaders
has been Rand Paul,
and this week,
he actually suggested
that Dr. Anthony Fauci
should be taken off TV
for continuing
to suggest caution
as cases continue to rise.
-There is no scientific evidence
that the lockdowns in Michigan
have done anything
or in California.
So there is no real correlation
between economic lockdowns,
mask mandates, or any of this.
So I think it's actually
television malpractice
for these TV doctors
to come on and say,
"Oh, the mask is so much more
important than the vaccine.
It's so much more of
an immediate benefit."
Dr. Fauci should be
voluntarily removed from TV,
because what he says
is such a disservice
and such fearmongering,
and almost all of what he says
isn't even matched by the
science of his own institute.
-I'm sorry,
you want Fauci off TV?
If I had to choose between
the kindly world-renowned
infectious disease expert
who was played by Brad Pitt
on "SNL"
or the guy
who looks like a puppet
fired by the Jim Henson workshop
for stealing office supplies,
I'd go with Fauci.
Also, does this mean
you're trying to cancel Fauci?
You guys accuse the left of
trying to cancel Dr. Seuss,
and now you're trying to cancel
an actual doctor?
If this keeps up, Republicans
are going to try to cancel
actual potatoes.
Also, I like how Rand Paul
wants to cancel Fauci,
but in order to avoid
using the word "cancel,"
he calls it voluntary removal.
That's just canceling
by another name.
NBC should have tried that. "We
didn't cancel 'Animal Practice.'
We voluntarily removed it
and burned all the tapes."
Paul won't stop
going after Fauci.
He seems determined to keep
spreading misinformation
about public health measures.
This week, Paul also tweeted,
"Fauci continues to ignore
100 years of vaccine science.
His only real theme is,
'Do what I say,
even when it makes no sense.'
If you've recovered
or been vaccinated,
go about your life.
Eat, drink, work,
open the schools.
Enough with the petty tyrants!"
He is a petty tyrant.
You guys are the ones
trying to cancel baseball.
You can't get more anti-American
than going after baseball.
What you going to do?
Take up cricket?
Which, honestly,
would look less ridiculous
than what Rand Paul
usually wears.
Also, how can you say
that wearing masks
and keeping people
physically apart from each other
doesn't stop the virus
from spreading?
It's literally based on
the germ theory of disease,
which is centuries old
and was popularized by,
among other famous figure,
Louis Pasteur.
I shouldn't have to
explain this to you.
I'm just a late-night host.
I barely paid attention
in high school.
I was hanging
in the back of math class,
making all my friends laugh
by doing hilarious stuff,
like typing "ace of base"
upside down on a calculator.
And then when the teacher
asked me to go up to the board
and identify the curve,
I'd write, "I saw the sine."
Another one
for the TikTok crowd.
Come up with a dance for that.
What? You won't?
Why, too busy?
Oh, you just don't like it?
Okay.
Thanks for the feedback.
Republicans decry
supposed cancel culture,
but that's exactly what
they're engaged in right now.
They want to use their platforms
and the power of the state
to cancel anyone
they disagree with,
from Anthony Fauci to
Major League Baseball.
Rand Paul is up for reelection
in 2022.
And if you ask me,
he should be...
-Voluntarily removed.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated.
We love you.